so strange to be standing out here again
I almost didn't make it I escaped
barely if only Oh
destiny cannot be changed Westgard is
under attack
yet the sheikin the only remaining link
between the people of here are still
holding out but for how long
change is in the air a new dawn is about
to begin but never is darkness deeper
than before the new door har [ __ ] of
doom are spreading throughout the world
Theo is breaking apart the nameless
demons of pure cross hunger to kill
everything living driven by their
leaders a suit
these creatures know no bounds I was
there he was set free I felt his range
is hot
I felt the doom he is about to bring
down upon us
but who is he what is he what makes him
that power
with him at their head the nameless will
destroy everything we know not even the
sight can with their dragons can resist
his road to soul intertwined the
Schafer's for soars as roots return but
they are gone and can't give answers to
those most pressing of questions our
greeting says when darkness is deepest
the Silver Weaver will guide your way
will the gods finally step in how was a
suit imprisoned in the first place why
did the gods choose this sheikin to
bring about it's as hoots freedom and
why did they choose my daughter for it I
am Craig Koons shellac sent by my god
and friend area but why did he send me
to the wastelands of sorrow to witness
the beginning of Doom to see my daughter
die
to come too late darkness is deepest but
the Silver Weaver and the god of
knowledge and wisdom guide my way and if
anyone can bring a new dawn then it's
the shaken